hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and
today I'm watching Street Fighter I grew
up playing Street Fighter I played it in
arcades and I played it on certain
consoles that we had ultimately I was
never good at it I was a very big
advocate of button magic I've always
thought that doing a cosplay from Street
Fighter would be so much fun got some
great characters I hear that it's not a
good film but like if they get some cool
characters it's like some cool costumes
I don't know it might like it might keep
my interest just some badass ladies just
like doing kung fu you know what I mean
like I want to see that I'm wondering
how much of the game they're gonna bring
into this and like what the main story
arc is gonna because from where I
remember the game is just isn't it just
fighting isn't just fighting on the
streets I am keeping an open mind for
this as one what we'll see
[Music]
you
I mean I'm gonna be honest I didn't hate
it the acting was hilarious it was
either like you're witty too good for
this or what the hell are you doing the
characters were so just it was they were
everywhere there's so many characters
doing so many things it's like infinity
war but an infinity war it's all these
groups of people doing things I
understand what they're doing and I also
know these characters this is like
here's this one I don't know I forget
who you are but like you're doing
everything you're doing all of this
stuff and there's just people everywhere
you and all these different things
tons of storylines it's like ah I don't
know you didn't have to put everybody in
it i groped there are a lot of
characters up front so I'm not super
sure what's happening but I'm loving it
but at a doctor I'm gonna need raju leah
was amazing
pretty sure I'm saying his name right I
know that he passed away and I think
this was his last film but my god was he
the best part of this movie he was
ridiculous in such a good way so
dramatic so fun to watch so crazy
entertaining some of his lines the of
course I know that's a big thing with
nostalgia go to people and I had no idea
where it was from but to watching this
movie and and the the it's Tuesday line
and like it's just so many good things
that I just don't know that I would have
liked this movie as much had he not been
in it I know I wouldn't I know I would
not have enjoyed this movie nearly as
much if this guy just didn't just knock
it out of the park
I'm d'squared ass 90s film and then
respectfully on the other side of that
is jean-claude Van Damme
whoo my god is such an awkward actor
holy moly
you can't understand what are you saying
and also like nothing plays like getting
none of his jokes work and it just
doesn't and nothing works none of it
works ah so bison the villain of the
film the best character ever to be
created has some people held captive and
it is jean-claude Van Damme's character
as his friend is captain's name is
Charlie and they're doing experiments on
Charlie to make him like a super soldier
type guy it would just just turns out to
be like fake Hulk rip off Hulk and it's
not well done but they have him in there
they're doing experiments on them
they're pumping and full of like muscles
and trying to enhance his body and the
bags of things that they're enhancing
him with look through an IV it's like
pink and green Gatorade and it's
ridiculous like DNA mutagen and diabolic
plasma ah yes honestly though the story
is just everywhere there's just here's a
big fight here's a big fight here's the
big unneeded fight there's a fight fight
fight fight fight fight fight and this
story is just a like it's a bit money
there's these con men and then you know
there's the whole chun-li story and then
there's the Claude Van Damme story and
his soldiers and there's just like the
you know the Bisons there's all the
stories happening and it's a lot before
something that does not need to be alive
yeah I'm saying there's also a lot of
weird I hesitate to say this word this
very 90s and very like video game
character II but there's a bit of this a
bit of some sexism wit maybe the
relationship between the colonel between
Shelley she finds out that he's not dead
and he doesn't want her to spill the
beans so he's gonna lock her up and
she's like please I will not spill the
beans I've been working my whole 20
years of this career towards like taking
the
down please don't lock me up and he's
like I don't really care I'm gonna lock
you up anyways but you can't understand
what I'm saying because I've got an
insane accent and she's like alright
chill then I'm gonna peace out and she
escapes and he's like what a woman and
even though she he was like trying to -
her dreams they're definitely gonna bone
and it's like it's a little it's a
little weird like at the very end she's
like can I have that interview now he's
like only if you wear that dress that's
slutty slutty awesome badass sexy dress
and everyone's like oh hilarious and it
is truly to where it definitely didn't
bother me it was just hilarious and then
bison says that he's planning on
kidnapping the Queen of England so it's
fun it's fun
so bison captures chun-li she's trying
to take him down after she escaped from
the colonel and he's like I know women
and you're harmless then he gases then
he gasses gently and the con artists
guys and it's like that got dark that
was we were about here on action and
then it was just like BAM fuck gassing
people so jean-claude van damme kills
bison and then bison suit starts like
bringing him back to life like with the
energy like shockwaves to the heart and
like sending adrenaline like an
injection of adrenaline his jacket is
just doing this shit like that's the
coolest like tech thing in this movie
like that is definitely the coolest like
gadget thing that they've got going on I
don't think I've ever seen that before
and I was like oh shit they all escape
except for the knockoff Hulk bison is
killed by old Colonels jean-claude Van
Damme and Chumlee definitely end up
together
it's pretty damn enjoyable honestly lots
of fighting the story was pretty muddy
the characters were all over the place
and their characters that like we kind
of know but not well enough to like
follow in a story like this there's just
too many people too many cooks video
game movies have come so far honestly
this was a mess it was a big it
seemingly big budget mess there are so
many RAL Giulia tweets and predictions
that I you know would talk about that
and it is it's so sad he's a national
treasure we didn't deserve how amazing
he is even in this shitty movie he pulls
out all the stops
so agreed I've only ever seen him in the
Addams Family and I loved him in that
but are there any other movies that I
should watch with him in them because
people love him better than the Mortal
Kombat movie don't add me I got to do
that too I haven't seen you will wonder
how John Claude Van Damme became so
famous when no one can understand him I
don't know that I didn't know that he
was famous I don't know what he's from
what is he from Oh
Tamara it's almost like you have a small
computer in your hands and you could
look that up what you'll question who
thought it would be a good idea to have
that many characters shoehorned into one
mediocre movie yeah it was a lot it was
very intensely filled with characters it
was like I don't care like half of these
people could have just easily been
written now the actress playing chun-li
is the voice of Mulan proof the
greatness comes once you start from the
bottom
damn damn good Fuhrer I really did
actually enjoy her she was pretty badass
when will my rifle
show Who I am of course it's not as bad
as you think honestly I just had a
problem with there being so many
characters but it was pretty fun there
was a lot of moments that were fun the
overacting was hilarious jean-claude van
damme being so bad was hilarious and and
our villain was just
moi gorgeous beautiful give me way more
I I thought I was gonna hate this one
you guys and I did I didn't hate it what
a lovely surprise
you know it to be like ah man I have to
watch this terrible movie and then it's
okay that's the best that's the dream
living the dream
thank you so much for watching this I
will see you guys all next week with
Jupiter ascending
[Music]
[Applause]
you